John Wetenhall:
One of the wonderful things about this show is we're really trying to...
trying to include a wide variety, from dance to drama to
John Wetenhall:
music, singing and everything.
And so, Princeton really does a great job of nurturing that.
John Wetenhall:
And I think that this show is a perfect example of it.
Triangle Club performers:
When the weather gets too chilly for Bermuda shorts,
take those red flannel longings off the hook.
Triangle Club performers:
Just be sure that that trap has a button-down flap.
Ya gotta have that Ivy League look.
Jess Turner:
There are so many good musicians who just want
to play around campus. And that's a really
Jess Turner:
energizing feel. It's a very free, encouraging
environment here at Princeton.
[singing]
Shere Khan singers:
One thing I can tell you is you've got to be free.
Come together right now, over me.
[singing]
Julia Blount:
When I came to Princeton, I had done some theater in high
school, but wasn't really planning on doing
Julia Blount:
any in college. But I came across some really
great people in the community here, who really encouraged me
Julia Blount:
to audition and do more shows.
And I've made some really great friends doing that.
Actor:
Lucy, tell Mrs. Hanes I must talk to her
alone before supper.
Actor:
Oh, Peggy, how are you my child?
All right, Countess Delage.
Actor:
I've been galloping madly over the desert all day.
Student:
There's so many different forms of dance that I was never exposed to before.
And there's always something that you can find that's interesting to you.
[music]
Louisa Ferguson:
This show is really great, because it incorporates all
of Princeton's performing arts groups, from Indian dance, to
Louisa Ferguson:
bands, to individual performers.
Phyllis Heitjan:
Someday I'll wish upon a star and wake up where the
clouds are far behind me.
Phyllis Heitjan:
Where troubles melt like lemon drops away above
the chimney tops.
Chiraag Galaiya:
If you're thinking about the arts at all, just go for it.
Don't be afraid or anything because you'll find something,
Chiraag Galaiya:
somewhere that you'll belong, and you'll probably end up having a great time.
Shere Khan singers:
And in the end, the love you take is equal to the
love you make.
[applause]